pandemics victims in the united states
include more than 28 thousand grocery
store workers who have tested positive
or been exposed to covet 19. hazard pay
for many of them
ended months ago jonathan bigliotti's in
long beach california where the city
council recently passed
what they're calling a hero pay
ordinance for its grocery workers
good morning to you jonathan has there
been any push back to the new rule
and good morning to you gail there has
been a lot of pushback primarily from
kroger the parent company of this food
for less they say
they can't afford to keep this store
open but employees that i have spoken
with say
that this store has never been busier
anyone that has been in a grocery store
can relate you're going to hear from one
woman
who says this is a form of retaliation
simply for asking for hazard pay
she believes she deserves
bertha ayala has worked the butcher
counter at the long beach food for less
for 14 years last year was the busiest
and hardest when you go to work every
day do you
worry about your health oh yeah i'm very
worried
worried for good reason she's diabetic
61 years old
and working six days a week because she
was told her job
is essential do you feel like food for
less
recognizes you as a hero they said but i
don't believe it
it sounds like you're saying they're not
putting their money where their mouth is
yeah and i feel like we are not
important
to them when long beach passed a mandate
for hazard pay late last month
requiring chain grocery stores to pay
four dollars an hour more for at least
120 days
parent company kroger announced the
store was one of two closing
their reason the store couldn't afford
to stay open
do you feel like you're stuck in the
middle of politics here yes
ayala's union says her food for less
store saw sales from march to august
rise 29 percent from the year before
and says according to financial records
kroger the largest grocery chain
in the country earned twice as much last
year
as the previous year the hero pay
ordinance has also prompted a lawsuit
from the california grocers association
ron fong is the group's president you
know the one thing that we do agree with
is that our employees are our heroes
however it is really unprecedented to
have a city council
demand what businesses should do with
their wages
fong says grocers should decide if they
want to give employees hazard pay
and some have two dollars it's three
dollars
it's gift cards gas cards they are our
heroes
and we have done everything possible
that we can to keep them safe in our
grocery stores
bertha says kroger has given her a few
gift cards to spend in its company's
stores
but they're inconsistent and
insufficient to hazard pay
now she faces a pandemic without a job
or health insurance it's like hard to go
to see the doctor very often
so this job's a lifeline for you are you
scared i'm really scared
and bertha says she wants her hazard pay
but more importantly
she just wants to keep her job in a
statement kroger says this ordinance
unfairly targets big chains and they go
on to say
they blame the city council for quote
overstepping the traditional
bargaining process here it's important
to point out the union that represents
workers in this district says in the
past 12 months
more than 1800 employees have fallen ill
from covid scale that puts it in
perspective
a lot of birth is out there working just
to make sure that we all can eat thank
you jonathan